welcome everybody to part three of our
google cloud tutorial series as well as
the second part of the vision API
tutorials the last one we just kind of
shows the basics of just detecting
labels and kind of like a description of
what's in the image that you're showing
it we kind of sort of touched on getting
the methods and stuff that you can run
against various you know objects that
we're getting from the Google cloud API
now in this one what I want to do is
just show a couple more things on the
vision API before we move on to another
API so the first thing I want to do is
pop over here I'm going to come to the
Python program Internet we'll go to data
analysis machine learning and then what
I'm going to do is just take this
machine learning image so I'm going to
right click copy image address and then
I'm going to come into here I'm going to
quit quit there we go
out of there mute the sound and I'm
going to go ahead and do it W get that
image and now we've got this image here
right click there and then let's go into
trying to set if I want to go into
vision I guess yeah we'll we'll uh we'll
minnow fish
next up hi I'm going to change the file
name here to that machine learning
playlist and what I'm going to do is let
me just I'm just going to do ctrl K
that'll get rid of these lines here and
actually well it's truly it's gone I
want to go ahead and just highlight this
now I'm going to copy this exit I'm
going to hit no and then we're just
going to get back into an interactive
Python so now I'll right click just to
copy everything into here alright so one
thing that we can do is like we've as
you can see with IO basically what's
returned is this image bar you missed
check and make sure it's on screen owns
all as well let's do
Derr image just so we can see what do we
have in just this like what is basically
the vision client image returning to us
so again with the underscores we'll just
kind of ignore those but we can do as
dict which I guess will convert it to
addiction added some something about
client content we can do the text we can
detect crop hints probably a crop the
image automatically detect faces find
faces detectable text labels landmarks
logos properties safe search which is
actually pretty interesting text web and
source so this one's kind of cool it'll
detect whether or not you have basically
pornographic images so it's kind of neat
now what I want to do is so this image
was just like an image rights machine
learning over a kind of a non clear
background opens back up so one thing
that we can do is like let's print just
print image text underscore text okay so
you get this kind of like object right
so again we can do dirt image dot text
underscore text what do we get then sure
enough we gets kind of use usual things
append count extend index pop all that
so you got that we can kind of assume
it's an iterable again so we're going to
say for text and image underscore or
image dot detect underscore text now we
can print dirt x to figure out what
we're going to do with this okay
so again we've got a description API
wrapper locale locations mid and score
so probably description is probably the
best one we're going to go with so and
then scores kind of interesting because
score basically tells you how confident
it is about this thing's presence so
again for text
or let's go ahead and just print let's
print text dot description text dot
score so the interesting lis enough this
scores are zero zero sometimes I see
that happen then I'm not quite positive
why because it's absolutely started in
usually but whatever I'll ignore that
for now I bet with the grito picture we
get more interesting scores anyway you
can see up here it detected both machine
and learning and then here just detected
machine and then it also detected
learning so it's a decade the full body
of text and then each word as well so
now what I want to do is let's get
another one so this one I've already
just kind of saved I just took a
screenshot basically of some text so
going into deposit per minute slash
static /downloads Google Cloud gute
Orioles block of text
PNG I'm going to take that copy I'm
going to come back over here let's put
out of here W get that file name again
block of text up PNG it's not too hard I
can remember that block G was that block
of text and let's just do this copy no
okay so the other thing that we had was
that um was another option for image so
again let's just do to her image again
just so I can show it
we had detect text but there's also just
detect full text so detect text could be
used to detect text that just so happens
to be an image but then you might also
have an image that is text so we might
want to use detect full text so for
example we can let's print brush we
don't need to print or in their
interactive looks like the image dots is
tech
underscore hole underscored text I'm
just going to save us some time I know
that has a dot text attribute or method
to run on here so but normally you
wouldn't know it returns this but you
could do it and see it anyway
okay so this is everything so as you can
see for each major algorithm that we
cover we're going to discuss the high
newline level and if we go over here we
can see the high newline level into it
right so it's also kind of noting where
the new lines are so you could just
forget rid of the new lines if you
wanted but anyway so it's pretty cool so
the last thing I want us to go ahead and
do is part of me wants to do that guido
image again just so i could show you the
score because i'm pretty sure the score
will be there so let me do so let's just
let me copy this copy not positive that
copied what they did nano vision example
oh it's already in there how I guess
because we've never saved it label dot
description and then let's do label dot
score just so you can see how confident
it is in that label being like you know
this is what's in the image so let's do
vision next up vision X I move my mouse
could see hi oh it's the run Python of
course and vision X pipeline okay it's
easy it's very confident that there's
hair in the picture there's a face a
person facial hair they've got a nose a
chin they've got some sort of hairstyle
um I got rid of the image oh well anyway
a beard head and even prepare the
confidence of senior citizen so I
actually got how cool clue is a little
bit yeah let's go let it let's go visit
his page one more time awesome how old
are you readable 61 I think isn't it 65
to be a senior citizens nothing's quite
right and I wonder when this picture
yeah this picture was taken in 2006 so
actually 11 years
so this is him at age 50 ouch
anyway yeah
record so that's the vision API if you
have any more questions comments
concerns whatever on the vision API feel
free to leave them below otherwise I'm
probably going to move on to a new API
the other thing I do I guess I kind of
want to show I can't remember if it was
dot Luke or location I kind of want to
I'm not gonna do it anyway if you try to
get the location of these various things
like wouldn't it be nice if it was like
beard and it like had the coordinates of
the beard and the coordinates of hair
and nose and all the things that it's
all here that would have been pretty
convenient but for some reason it just
doesn't the location doesn't seem good
return on location so anyway if anybody
finds an image where location actually
works or can figure out why location is
returning nothing let me know I'd love
to know like where you know how to get
it to recognize where certain things are
in the image that's really helpful
anyway that's that questions comments
link below otherwise I will see you in
another Google cloud tutorial